[Music]
leave the neon signs on the strip and
head to tivoli village for neon pumpkins
we created the twisted pumpkin which is
a pumpkin painting neon glow experience
primarily for young children up to
adults and even for awkward dates first
stop the indoor and very instagramable
pumpkin patch you'll select whatever
type of real or artificial pumpkin that
you so choose and then we're going to
set you up with neon glow paints and
your own interactive table this fun
unique and potentially awkward
experience is timed for 90 minutes so
once you're waiting for your pumpkin art
to dry you know it wouldn't be so vegas
without games drinks and a vip lounge to
enjoy
yep you can get twisted responsibly of
course at the twisted pumpkins calavera
cantina which is an exclusive 21 up
cantina that adults can meander in or
leisure at their convenience so take
your pick the el diablo the paloma or
the halloween orchata the twisted
pumpkins clearly ready for dia de los
muertos too we'll be having a special
party here on november 2nd for dia de
los buertos it's a five dollar entry
we're gonna bring in a live dj and we're
gonna be raffling off some one-of-a-kind
pieces of artwork that five local tattoo
shops competed for oh and on your way
out don't forget before the clock
strikes midnight and your twisted
pumpkin comes alive
just kidding take some time to capture
the moment with your new neon fall decor
[Music]